queremos probar la hipótesis de que más
del 30 por ciento de los hogares en eeuu
tienen acceso a internet con un nivel de
significación del 5% se toma una muestra
de 150 hogares y se encontró que 57
tienen acceso a internet para hacer la
prueba de nuestras hipótesis tenemos que
establecer nuestra hipótesis cero y
nuestra hipótesis alternativa por lo que
nuestra hipótesis cero es que este
enunciado no es correcto
la hipótesis cero indica que es menos de
la proporción de hogares en eeuu que
tienen acceso a internet va a ser menor
o igual que el 30% y nuestra hipótesis
alternativa es que en efecto la
proporción va a ser mayor que el 30%
como ven queremos probar la hipótesis de
que existen más del 30 por ciento de
hogares en eeuu que tienen acceso a
internet esto de aquí es lo que estamos
probando la hipótesis alternativa la
forma en que vamos a hacer esto es que
vamos a asumir
valor p con base en la hipótesis 0 una
proporción con base en la población y
asumiendo esto cuál será la probabilidad
de que 57 de los 150 elementos en
nuestra muestra en realidad tienen
acceso a internet
y si esa probabilidad es menor al 5%
si es menor a nuestro nivel de
significación entonces tendremos que
rechazar la hipótesis cero y por lo
tanto la hipótesis 1 será la aprobada
cómo vamos a resolver esto bueno vamos a
comenzar asumiendo vamos a asumir que la
hipótesis 0 es verdadera y al asumir
esto vamos a tener que elegir una
proporción de la población o una media
de la población sabemos que por la
distribución de bernal y ambas son lo
mismo y lo que voy a hacer es elegir una
proporción tan alta que maximiza la
probabilidad de obtener esto y de hecho
aún no sabemos qué número será este así
que vamos a pensar un poquito mejor
vamos primero encontrar cuál es la
proporción de nuestra población 57
elementos de nuestros 150 tienen acceso
a internet
la proporción de nuestra muestra desde
punto 38 vamos a escribirlo
la proporción de nuestra muestra es
igual a 0.38 cuando asumimos que nuestra
hipótesis 0 es correcta o es verdadera
vamos a asumir nuestra proporción la
proporción de nuestra población que
maximice que maximice la probabilidad de
obtener esto de acá así que la
proporción de la población más alta que
tenemos para nuestra hipótesis 0 que
maximiza la probabilidad de obtener esto
es si estuviéramos justo en el 30% si
decimos que nuestra proporción de la
población asumiendo que esto es verdad
que la hipótesis 0 es verdadera vamos a
asumir que es igual a 0.3 y quiero que
comprendan esto pudimos haber usado un
29% o un 28% ya que ambos hubieran
estado dentro de nuestra hipótesis cero
pero para el 29 o el 28% la probabilidad
de obtener esto hubiera sido aún más
baja si tomamos el máximo la proporción
máxima que aún satisface nuestra
hipótesis 0 pues vamos a maximizar las
probabilidades
y obtengamos esto este número es aún
bajo a una es menor al 5% podemos
confiar en la hipótesis alternativa y
ahora para refrescarnos un poco vamos a
asumir una proporción de la población de
punto 3 y bueno vamos a dibujar la
distribución porque a veces esto ayuda
mucho a comprender un problema así que
vamos a dibujarla esta es la
distribución de la población con base en
lo que estamos asumiendo lo que estamos
asumiendo aquí arriba la distribución de
la población tiene un 30% que tiene
acceso a internet les vamos a asignar
valor 1 y el resto no tiene acceso a
internet
el resto no tiene acceso a internet es
el 70 por ciento y le asignamos el valor
esta es una distribución de bernal y
sabemos que la media de esta
distribución va a ser la misma que la
proporción de los que tienen acceso a
internet por lo que la media
de esta distribución va a caer por acá y
va a ser igual a 0.3
el 30 por ciento esa es la media de la
población no consumir mejor lo vamos a
escribir así la media asumiendo
asumiendo que es verdadera la hipótesis
0 la media de la población va a ser
igual a 0.3 y la desviación estándar de
la población lo vamos a escribir aquí en
amarillo la desviación estándar de la
población asumiendo que la hipótesis 0
es verdadera vimos esto cuando
aprendimos sobre la distribución de
berlín que esta desviación estándar va a
ser igual va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de el
porcentaje de la población que tiene
acceso a internet en este caso es punto
3 x el porcentaje de la población que no
tiene acceso a internet que esto es
punto 7 por lo que esto va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 7 por 3 21.21 y más
adelante vamos a resolver esto usando
nuestra calculadora pero haciendo un
lado esto
encontrar la probabilidad de encontrar
una proporción de la muestra que sea de
punto 3 ahora vamos a ver la
distribución de las proporciones de las
muestras y literalmente podríamos ver
cada una de las combinaciones de los 250
hogares y obtener a partir de ello una
distribución binomial vamos a dibujar y
esto ya lo hemos visto antes también en
donde hay una distribución binomial con
un conjunto de barras tenemos varias
barras como estas pero si n es lo
suficientemente grande en particular y
esta es una prueba de ello la prueba de
que n por p y en este caso p es igual al
30%
sea mayor que 5 y que m por 1 p sea
mayor que 5 se puede asumir que la
distribución de las proporciones de la
muestra va a ser normal si pudiéramos
ver las diferentes combinaciones de
muestras nuestros 150 hogares de esta
población tendríamos todas estas barras
ya que no está m es bastante grande 150
x p es mayor que 5 y 150 por punto 7
también es mayor que 5 por lo que esto
se aproxima a la distribución normal
vamos a dibujarlo lo aproximamos con una
distribución normal que estoy poniendo
en magenta
y esa es nuestra distribución normal y
ahora la media de la distribución de la
proporción de la información asumiendo
que se trata de una distribución normal
va a ser y acuérdense que estamos
trabajando en el contexto de que la
hipótesis cero es verdadera por lo que
esta media va a ser la media en rosa de
nuestra proporción de la muestra va a
ser igual a la media de nuestra
población por lo tanto esto va a ser
igual a 0.3 el mismo valor que la media
y nuestra desviación estándar esto viene
del teorema del límite central la
desviación estándar de las proporciones
de nuestra muestra va a ser igual a la
raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada no no no a ver va a ser
igual
la desviación estándar de la población
la desviación estándar de nuestra
población asumiendo que es verdadera la
hipótesis 0 dividido entre la raíz
cuadrada del número de muestras que en
este caso es igual a 150 y ahora vamos a
calcular todo esto este número de aquí
arriba encontramos que es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de punto 21 raíz cuadrada
de punto 21 entre la raíz cuadrada de
150 raíz cuadrada de 150
sacamos nuestra calculadora para hacer
la operación por lo que
vamos a hacerlo tal cual escribimos la
raíz cuadrada de punto 21
y voy a dividir esto entre la raíz
cuadrada de 150
el resultado es punto 0 37
y encontramos que la desviación estándar
de la distribución de la proporción de
las muestras
va a ser igual a vamos a hacer un
espacio
0.0 37
chispas me estoy quedando sin espacio
aquí ahora para calcular la probabilidad
de tener una proporción de la muestra
punto 38 tenemos que encontrar cuántas
desviaciones estándares están alejadas
de nuestra media o esencialmente
calcular una estadística zeta para
nuestra muestra ya que la estadística
zeta nos dice cuántas desviaciones
estándares estamos alejados de la media
y para calcular la probabilidad de
obtener esa estadística z es más o menos
el 5%
así pues vamos a calcular cuántas
desviaciones estándares estamos alejados
de la media y solamente para recordarnos
esto la proporción de muestreo que
tenemos podemos verla como una muestra
de la distribución de todas las muestras
posibles así que bueno cuantas
desviaciones estándares estamos alejados
de la media si tomamos nuestra
proporción de muestreo y la restamos la
media de la distribución de las
proporciones muestrales o de muestreo y
todo esto lo dividimos entre la
desviación estándar de la distribución
de las proporciones muestrales obtenemos
punto 38 - punto 3
dividido entre este valor que acabamos
de calcular que es 0.03 7 y esto que va
a ser igual
bueno el numerador va a ser
y 0.08 dividido entre 0.0 37 vamos a
calcular esto con nuestra hermosa
calculadora punto 08 dividido entre
punto 0 37 o este valor que tuvimos
antes en la respuesta anterior
es igual a 2.13 vamos a redondear lo a
2.14 desviaciones estándares esto es
igual a
esto de aquí que estoy señalando aquí es
igual a 2.14 desviaciones estándares y
podemos decir que nuestra estadística
zeta podemos llamar esto nuestro puntaje
z o nuestra estadística zeta o el número
de divisiones estándar es que estamos
alejados de la media es de 2.14 y para
ser precisos son dos puntos catorce
desviaciones estándares por encima de la
media ahora la pregunta es acaso la
probabilidad de obtener esto más o menos
del 5% si es menos del 5% vamos a
rechazar la hipótesis cero y favorecer
la hipótesis alternativa como
encontramos esto pensemos en una
distribución normal normalizada o
podemos llamarla una distribución zeta
si quiere en una distribución normal
normalizada
su media se va a encontrar en 0
su media es 0 y esencialmente cada uno
de estos valores son puntaje z
aquí tenemos uno literalmente quiere
decir que estamos a una desviación
estándar de la media si definimos un
valor z crítico
definimos el valor z crítico aquí aquí
le ponemos
se está crítica
o puntaje z crítico o valor z crítico
la probabilidad de obtener un valor z
mayor que este es del 5% esta área de
aquí es del 5% y esto es porque este es
nuestro nivel de significación cualquier
cosa que esté por debajo del 5% de
probabilidad de ocurrir para nosotros va
a ser la validación para rechazar
nuestra hipótesis 0 otra forma de verlo
es que toda esta área que estoy
subrayando en azul es el 95% y de nuevo
este es solo una cauda para probar
porque solo nos interesan valores que
estén por encima de este nivel valores z
mayores harán que se valide nuestra
hipótesis y para calcular este valor se
está crítico pues podemos ir a nuestra
tabla zeta y vemos qué valor z la
probabilidad de obtener un valor z menor
que este sea del 95% y eso es
exactamente lo que nos da este número la
probabilidad acumulada de obtener un
valor menor a este así que estamos
buscando aquí estas celdas para
encontrar un valor de punto 95 lo que
más se acerque y creo que este es para
asegurarnos que estemos un poco más
cerca o lo más cerca posible este valor
le corresponde a las coordenadas 1.6 y
su siguiente dígito es 51 puntos 65 por
lo que nuestro valor crítico z va a ser
igual a 1.65 por lo que la probabilidad
de obtener un valor z menor que 1.65 y
recordamos que en una distribución
normal normalizada la probabilidad de
obtener un valor menor que 1.65 o de
hecho también se aplica en cualquier
distribución normal esta probabilidad de
estar por debajo de 1.65 desviaciones
estándar es lejos de la media será del
95% y este es nuestro valor z crítico
ahora la estadística zeta para nuestra
muestra es 2.14
tomando en cuenta estos valores vemos
que la probabilidad es definitivamente
menor que el 5%
incluso podríamos decir que la
probabilidad de obtener estas áreas más
pequeñas aún las podemos encontrar
viendo nuestra tabla zeta podemos
encontrar el valor p de este resultado
pero de cualquier manera todo este
ejercicio nos lleva a rechazar la
hipótesis cero con el nivel de
significación del 5% vemos que si se
pudo realizar mientras tengamos
resultados más extremos de nuestro valor
se está crítico podemos rechazar la
hipótesis cero y favorecer nuestra
hipótesis alternativa